je brosse dure aux blancs apprendre à
bien se brosser les dents savoir aussi
le vocabulaire dentaire dans de l'aide
en définitive ou dans du fond on a
toujours commencé à nettoyer nos dents
commence et comme on va commencer par le
haut ensuite ça va descendre la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie a donc
lancé il ya sept ans l'opération est
menée dans cette année cette animation
concerne douze classes de cp de la ville
de trappes comme ici à l'école jean macé
et la leçon retenue
les dogues ont préféré
comment se brossait déjà hélas bien je
pense qu'il a il a amélioré ce qu'il
avait déjà et pour les bonbons offre pas
trop manger autres le sont passées
auprès des enfants et de leurs parents
une brosse à dents cela ne se prêtent
pas et il faut éviter les boissons
sucrées le soir car l'ennemi à chasser
c'est bien à carrer quand on ne les
écoute c'est vrai pour eux se détachent
on passe par toutes les couleurs
ils n'ont vraiment pas conscience qu'il
s'agit d'un trou et samedi ont
réellement une dent et qu'on garde ça
pas toute sa vie ce dispositif de
sensibilisation dans les classes
s'accompagne d'une opération de
prévention gratuite tous les jeunes âgés
de 6 9 12 15 et 18 ans peuvent
bénéficier d'un examen de prévention
gratuit et des soins consécutifs
nécessaire une vraie réalité
80 % des enfants de 6 ans ne consultent
pas de chirurgien dentiste et 60% des
enfants issus de familles en difficulté
présentent des problèmes dentaires